good morning Hank it's Monday I think we
should do a theme week this week and I
think the theme should be open letters
to our fifteen-year-old brothers by the
way do you like my shirt is a rhetorical
question of course you like it dear
fifteen-year-old Hank
hi it's me John Green your brother I
know I look old 15 year old hope life is
a lot like peach jell-o Pizza America or
is it Italian or Greek or Brazilian
where they eat more pizza than anyone in
the whole world
more 6000 pizza Rios in Brazil fifth
album you video do be surreal Brazil
every day for 18 years before you had to
go to a place twice unless you were
eating pizza twice a day which let's
face it I would be so Hank you're 15
like a lot of 15 year-olds do you feel
like when you are forced to read books
in English class and look for metaphor
and symbolism and theme and all that
stuff you are sort of being tortured by
the way 15 year old Hank I am now an
author huh here's what critical reading
does Hank it helps us understand what to
think about and it gives us a framework
for how to think about those things okay
so let me give you an easy to comprehend
example what I'm talking about from this
famously incomprehensible james joyce
novel Ulysses I'm getting to the pizza
so there's this Irish Jewish guy bloom
and he's sitting in a bar and one of the
guys he's talking to John wise says but
do you know what a nation means a nation
says bloom a nation is the same people
living in the same place and then
everybody starts to make fun of bloom
for a stupid definition and then bloom
ads are also living in different places
but then it's all the characters in the
novel or laughing at bloom the reader
realizes that you know we don't have a
better definition for what constitutes a
nation or indeed what it means to have
membership in any community I mean bloom
is in this weird in-between space
because he's Irish but he's also Jewish
which many characters in the novel see
as inherently uh nyah
but ultimately we all want to feel like
we're on the inside of our communities
whether it's Ireland or the United
States or a high school clique or
nerdfighteria and the question of
whether there have to be Outsiders in
order for there to be insiders turns out
to be a really interesting and difficult
and complicated question which is
explored at length in Ulysses and
thinking about as the guys at the bar
clearly can't what we really mean when
we talk about these identifiers z' is a
much better starting place for
conversations about who is or is not
American or who is or is not a
nerdfighter rather than the current
method of discourse which is just to be
like ah
Levante garages form of communicating
hurts not only the quality of discourse
but also the quality of my glasses which
brings me to Pizza Hank is Pizza
American certainly there's a lot of
pizza in America
thank goodness what pizza was originally
Italian although Italian pizza doesn't
taste very much like this because this
pizza is fortified with sodium which is
a mineral or a vitamin all I know is
that it's good for you
in fact think pizza so ubiquitous it's a
little bit difficult to say what Pizza
even is I mean sometimes it comes
without cheese sometimes it comes
without sauce sometimes it comes without
a crust in a bucket and people are the
same way Hank a nation is the same
people living in the same place or also
in different places there are Italians
in Italy and there are Italians in
America and there are Italians of
Chilean descent everyone's laughing at
Blumenau Barbara we should be the ones
laughing it down they think there's some
easy uncomplicated definition of
Irishness but in fact the fundamental
thing that all critical reading does is
reveal to us that there are not easy
definitions that distinguish us from
them reading with an eye toward metaphor
allows us to become the person we're
reading about while reading about them
that's why there are symbols and books
and why your English teacher deserves
your attention ultimately it doesn't
matter if the author intended a symbol
to be there because the job of reading
is not to understand the author's intent
the job of reading is to use stories as
a way into seeing other people as we see
ourselves and when we do that we can
look out at the world and see a giant
endless set of beautiful variations of
pizzas the whole world composed of
billions of beautiful delicious pizzas
Hank I'll see you on Wednesday
did I make that entire video so that I
could eat one piece of pizza on my diet
maybe